it's an experience that causes dizziness
frustration and anger yes of course I'm
talking about surfing the web on your
phone oh sure everybody says mobile apps
are killing the web so why exactly am i
spending so much time in my phone as web
browser still okay
I could keep complaining about how Apple
Safari and Google's Chrome could use
some real improvements or I could tell
you how with some tricks you can turn
things around let's start with iPhone
owners if you have an Android phone
pause this video and jump ahead look for
a screen that looks like this with a
chrome logo
yes chrome is available for the iPhone
but Apple basically traps you into using
Safari since you can't change the
default browser now to the tips want to
find a specific word or phrase on a site
tap the share button and swipe over to
find on page or type the word or phrase
into the address bar then scroll down
and select on this page you can keep
swiping and swiping and swiping to get
back to a page you visited or you could
just hold down the back arrow to see all
your history who doesn't like a good
desktop site instead of going into the
menu hold down on the refresh button in
the top right Apple needs to rethink how
it manages tabs but for now at least you
can reorder them tap here then hold down
on the tab and drag it to where you want
accidentally close one I gotcha
hold down that plus button to see
previously closed tabs
hold down on the period key to add calm
to you or whatever to the end of your
web address if you're at the bottom of a
page tap on the clock at the top of the
screen to scroll back to the top
hello Android phone owners your phone
may have two browsers but you should be
using Chrome it's better and Google's
focused on improving it sadly most of
these tips won't work in Chrome for iOS
though first tip to find a word or
phrase on a page tap the three dots and
select find in page
to get to another tab you might have
open swipe right or left on the top
toolbar swipe down from the top of the
screen to see all your open tabs see a
phrase or something you want to look up
highlight the words tap the Box on the
bottom of the screen and the search
results will pop up one of the best
things about Chrome is its data saver
which only loads parts of the page turn
it on to save data and speed upload
times you know those sites where you
can't zoom in on anything in settings
under accessibility select force enable
zoom and you'll be able to pinch to zoom
in on anything know these tips won't fix
all your mobile problems so remember
even just half of these and you'll be
doing better than most people